[Musik]
habt ihr chancen habe ich selber einen
blick nach vorn
[Musik]
doch wie sehr das ziel über den monitor
die kamera dazu ist direkt oben auf der
wochenstation und hieß es von der als
bedingung war
aber das ist noch lange nicht alles
technische details zum usa er hat 185 ps
hat platz für vier personen und was mich
sehr beeindruckt da gibt's dazu flossen
bis zu 80 km/h war man wirklich will und
der vorausscheidung sga steigt dann geht
ab bis zu 130 km/h schnell
und das obwohl er sieben tonnen hat
[Musik]
das wirklich spezielle an den vortrag
ist aber die witterung dort drinnen ist
man sich ja vor beschuss von ihnen vor
sprengfallen und sogar von
granatsplittern
[Musik]
außerdem ist der user extrem beweglich
vom österreichischen bundesheer
eingesetzt als mehrzweckfahrzeug wie zum
beispiel zum aufklären oder für
transporte
[Musik]